uh
invigoration of investment activities
of russian businesses
as well
and uh my colleague
expressed a wish that russian business
also takes part in the economic
activities in korea
we also discussed the
uh nine bridges concept
which envisioned envisages cooperation
in a number of fields including
transport agriculture
education and healthcare
we had a detailed discussion
on
the future plans to fight the
coronavirus pandemic including
bilateral agreements
and also multilateral initiatives
promoted by country
as a part of our various summits
and we also
discussed in detail the situation on the
peninsula and in southeast asia as a
whole
we
believe that a diplomatic solution
should be possible and that talks should
be resumed by
all parties concerned
and we should understand that
the search for a long-term
uh comprehensive solution
should cover the whole range of issues
on the korean peninsula
and we need to
ensure that uh
no factors intervene that would lead to
increased tension
we also discussed uh
our ties
based on
u.n platforms
the g20 and
other mechanisms
we've discussed the situation in the
region which is still
called the asia pacific region
and we have
some issues with the
indo-pacific concept promoted by western
partners
but sir anyway it has been a pleasure to
be host to mr minister and his
delegation and we're very grateful
that they have accepted an invitation
and come to the closing of the
year of the cultural exchanges thank you
mr
thank you for welcome to russia
we had a very fruitful discussion today
russia is our close neighbor
and at the same time it's our strategic
partner
i'm
happy to have this meeting
with mr lavrov after
our meeting in the seal in march of this
year
over the last 14 years
we
exchanged meetings
of our foreign ministers
and
uh
it shows
our good will
and mutual relations
today we've exchanged our
opinions uh on
development of the situation on the
peninsula
and we agree that we need
keep our connections our ties uh between
our governments
and to
develop our bilateral relations
and as soon as
chronovirus situation is stabilized we
need to
ramp up our meetings
we've also
agreed that we need to continue our
strategic partnership
including in politic political sphere
and culture and etc
we also need to restore our trade and
turnover and today we have a 47 percent
uh increase in trade
compared to previous year
and
this is a good trend and we need to
promote our development
in post-coronavirus era
we continue to
develop a new
project
and we need
to put effort into creating
infrastructure
ship building health care
and other
items of 9 bridges strategy
we need to
develop
our industrial
complex
and
we need to continue this project because
it's a good example of our partnership
we have
a good developments in shipbuilding
especially in implementation of joint
projects
building uh
lng
tankers and other kinds of ships
we need to harmonize our
legal framework
to develop our partnership
and soon we'll have a
mutual trade agreement
and we need to
point out
prospective areas of industry
next
week
we'll have a
third
cooperation forum between russia and
south korea
different delegations from russia
regions will take part in it including
those from the far east and arctic
russia
we will
continue
developing ties
and
we highly praised
the fact that we had several events
uh during our cultural exchange year
these events took part in
were hosted
in online and offline formats
and this
play the troll in
strengthening our ties
and
in march and today we're closing this
year and i'm happy
for
our cooperation with mr minister
and we will continue developing ties
between our countries including in
health care and to overcome the
coronavirus
the
support russia supports uh cooperation
in healthcare in eastern asia
and
we will continue our
cooperation to
further develop our project
we've also agreed
that the north korean nuclear problem
needs to be solved and to do this we
will continue cooperation on different
levels in the korean peninsula
we need to
settle this conflict
and we've exchanged
our opinions on the issue
korea
highly praises the russian support
in strengthening
korean relations
and
we hope that russia will continue to
place
constructive role in stabilizing the
situation on the peninsula
and today we've
reaffirmed
that russia and south korea are good
partners
in supporting peace
in the peninsula and will
we are looking forward to the
partnership
so questions now
uh
commercial newspaper
mr lavrov have you discussed
the possibility of
north korean missiles in uh
in south korea
does this concerns russia or is there
any guarantees that there will be no
such missiles and could you please
comment
on
ukrainian drones in donbass thank you
as to the potential
a deployment
of
mid-range
uh land missiles
in korea was not discussed
for the simple reason that we're very
well aware of the principled stance of
the korean president against such a
deployment and if we talk about other
countries in the region and of course we
are concerned by
the
desire to
deploy
missile systems
declared by the united states not only
in europe but also in the asia pacific
we believe
that it would
be a serious detriment to the strategic
balance
that exists
and we
reaffirm
the proposals made by president putin
several years ago
to
the united states and other partners in
the west to impose a moratorium
with regard to
some countries in the world
while adopting verification measures
that would provide a confirmation
to the united states and to us
that such missiles
uh would not be deployed based on
facilities
that exist
in poland and in other countries but our
western colleagues
i refuse to impose such moratorium and
they are not willing to discuss anything
like that
and there is a
also some evidence that
the
planning officers at nato are looking
towards the east
and mr stoltenberg
has said that nato's mission should
extend
to
the
asia-pacific region
in their opinion their mission would
extend to the end of the world and i
think
such trends should be counted
and that all countries should
be aware
of
such attempts
and
of the dangers of such a course of
action
as to the probability that
turkish drones are used by the ukrainian
army
uh in donbass
we are currently double checking this
information
and the recent statements
which abound
um statements by ukrainian
authorities
it's really hard to
ascertain
which is truth and which is fiction so
we are coordinating
our information with uh
authorities and donbass and
these
this information
has probably been connected with at the
marionka village
where a provocation was
met by the donbass troops
and
no
additional
information has been provided
be discussed right now
but as uh
there is a now
effort
to
accelerate ukraine's accession to nato
this probably should be a case for
discussion
so
you've talked you've discussed uh
security in the korean peninsula
but did you talk about global challenges
many russians are concerned that the
south
asian-pacific alliance
draw their forces to our borders and
they're ready to
build
bases in ukraine and either any
diplomatic efforts to deter nato away
thank you
well this is something where diplomatic
efforts
are simply not enough
other measures are also needed
that would be commensurate to the
threats to
the security
of the russian federation and i can
assure you that the president
is monitoring this issue and
all the necessary measures both
diplomatic and otherwise are being taken
thank you
the press conference is over
is
[Music]
project
is
a